part of this video was sponsored by
Squarespace this is the Kilda it was the
Dutch currency for hundreds of years
then it
disappeared this was a shame not the
Euro but the death of the design its
colors outdid every dollar its
Lighthouse stood above all buildings and
its portraits embarrassed the queen some
say even killed her the Kilda changed
the face of cash forever I believe it's
the best paper money ever made but why
why was Dutch money so different why
does it look so
[Music]
strange Ocha oar was different he
designed government issued stamps with
dramatic playful colors then he used
brand new techniques like computer
generated Graphics to create complicated
geometrical patterns in the' 60s he made
the air flatters a series of five
portrait banknotes from the vundle rider
Hulse a painter sink a composer the
router a naval commander and of course
Spinosa together they all look kind of
odd oar's faces look more like they
belong in a comic than on a bank note
Dutch notes are very distinctive they
are unlike any other central banks notes
that I'm aware of visually very strong
King I could imagine that not everybody
likes them when you think of money you
think of value a medium for you to
exchange one thing for another but money
is also branding there millions of tiny
Billboards spread across an entire
country it's a place where a Nation
shows what it stands for a canvas to
display national heroes and icons so why
do oakar feel like he's making a joke
the notes had to have portraits on them
of famous
historical figures which would not
create any political problems portraits
are the most used images on currency and
they can be a bit touchy for some a
nation is nothing more than the sum of
its people we use portraits to hold some
up as lessons and
inspiration for others though portraits
can lift up people whose value system is
out of date maybe even threatening
statues intentional or not can be
monuments colonizers slave owners and
authoritarians maybe the same could be
said of the faces we put on currency
should Andrew Jackson a president and
also slave owner be replaced by Harriet
Tubman a slave emancipator should we
avoid figures entirely The Genius of
oar's designs is that it didn't matter
he neither avoided people entirely or
kept them he caricatured them this is
George Washington yeah president
and this is mikil
dout I mean
okay if you live in a country whose
banknotes scream take me seriously
keeping or removing a portrait will
always be a
controversy if you have Bank notes that
play the fool well then there's not much
of a throne to fight
over the air flatters changed portrait
currency but it's oen our second series
that turned it on its head he was asked
to replace the 100 Kilda and add a 50
and 250 bank note
for the 100 he replaces the naval
Commander not with someone else but with
a
bird this was crazy a snipe doesn't have
ties to citizenship it's a bird found in
marshy land that happens to be in the
Netherlands but it is by no means the
Netherlands for hundreds of years money
was intimately tied to the faces of
rulers Earth changing scientists and
artists henar played a joke on them all
he made the whole H Kilda the first bank
note in the Western World to no longer
be a portrait just a
bird with the 50 Kilda bank note he
changed it up again he proposes a
sunflower another object with no clear
ties to a nation but still an indirect
homage to B the glue had made the bee
fall off from the top onto the flower as
though it flew there the 50 Mark is
horizontal some of its text is vertical
this temps the owner to turn the bill
around you hand the cashier not money
but a
flower finally there's the lighthouse
oar's last and probably most beautiful
bank
note
hello where am I why hello there you're
in a Squarespace ad what is this who are
you Squarespace is the best website
builder on the Market it's the 21st
century you need a personal website what
are you even talking H that's actually a
fair point with squarespace's flexible
website templates and its new fluid
engine it's never been easier for anyone
to unlock unbreakable creativity when it
comes to designing your own website
launch a business and use squares spaces
analytics to build a marketing strategy
so you can make more money launch a Blog
and use squarespace's blogging tools to
share your stories photos videos and
updates check out squarespace.com for a
free trial and when you're ready to
launch go to squarespace.com
slh to save 10% off your first purchase
of a website or
domain Oar wanted to make currency that
symbolized the Netherlands without being
a cliche no windmills clogs cows or
tulips instead of projecting what the
Dutch are loudly Oaken are intentionally
chose symbols that were a bit more
normal he then took it a step further by
converting these symbols into security
features Bank notes need to be secured
against forgery that's why banks will
issue paper money with watermarks so the
bills are harder to copy oakar also
designed watermarks but they were
different instead of heads or Angels Oar
chose animals for the 100 The Watermark
is the head of a snipe on the flower
it's a bee and on the lighthouse a dune
[Music]
rabbit you can look through the note and
you see a a watermark that is a rabbit
it was a rabbit belonging to my
girlfriend everybody has to walk around
with my rabbit in their pocket I like
that on theill and on the sposa are
fingerprints I put something personal
into this my fingerprint in the hair of
one of the world's most important
philosophers
Spinosa very Unholy of me not very nice
the smudge of a finger is so sloppy that
no serious artist would dare to include
it oakar did it Anyway by the time that
the Dutch National Bank realized what
they were it was too late a joke in the
pockets of an entire population that is
the nice part of making bank notes you
can make monuments by the millions he
did the same for the lighthouse in the
beacon he hid three women's names his
granddaughter girlfriend and friend the
engraver had included these names also
completely unknown to the Dutch National
Bank the combination of security
features and oar's personal humor was a
reoccurring theme the smallest lettering
that you see in that white square well
this is meant so that when you are
sitting somewhere in a private place
like the toilet or somewhere like that
you have something to read another
counterfeiting technique is
microprinting banks will put tiny design
printed features onto a bank note this
makes it difficult for counterfeits to
reprint it accurately with a standard
photocopying machine this can be done by
printing small lines of text but that's
kind of boring it's a security feature
that's just kind of slapped on to the
design the artist comes along hands over
his sketches his ideas and then they
tell him the design had to be changed
that's our job we are responsible for
security
it's one way of doing it treating a bank
note design and its security feature as
separate jobs but there is also another
way you make the security features an
integral part of the design I said I
have to have unrestricted access to
every detail to every technique to every
secret otherwise I cannot make a good
design I must know what the techniques
are the bank accepted this you can add a
bunch of small thin lines because it
makes the bank note secure or you can
add a bunch of small thin lines because
it's necessary for it to look
good
for the 100 250 and 50 Kilda each had
their own simple primitive in the
background where you could find hundreds
of micr lines changing and adjusting to
different areas in a
grid were these necessary for the design
or for the security the beauty is that
you can't
tell
I chose very Elementary colors because
it was a small series of only five
values instead of single colors or muted
ones Oar f for vibrant Reds Blues
yellows and greens when I made my first
bank note the printers maintained that
more color was an impossibility they
said when you use a green it must be
very dark and blackish green otherwise
it's not safe I discovered that this was
not true I just had to keep on asking
and asking oar's Bank notes did not only
stand out next to single colored Bank
notes but they also stood Out Among the
colored ones it's almost as though oar's
banknotes were like Monopoly money which
is well exactly what they were the only
money I had seen which was as clear as I
wanted money to B was Monopoly money
that was nice money in my eyes so I hope
that my own work looks a little bit like
that you don't need to look at the
number on Monopoly money to recognize
its value the design is clear the layout
standardized and the topography loud
with the Hilda it was the same at a
moment's notice the faintest Glimpse you
could identify exactly which bank note
it was the specific colors that were
chosen were almost nearly perfect the
primary colors blue red and yellow are
the most visually clear for the human
eye oakar believe the notes which were
used the most should also reflect that
when the value of the money was higher
only then would you find the secondary
colors a dignified green or a royal
Violet if you're color blind you're
probably not getting this video but you
could also still determine the Hilda's
value from large legible letters the
objective was to use very clear
typography so that when you folded up
the note you could see what the value of
the bank note was at least four times
oar's designs were influential for the
Euro they didn't consider using separate
colors until the Dutch National Bank
submitted a proposal based on his
designs he changed the rules for what a
bank note could and should look like it
the Deep
In
by I think that
Sy